صلت الاداء المميز للمنتخب المغربي في كاس
العالم قطر 2022 الضوء على عدد من
اللاعبين الموهوبين الذين تخرجوا من
اكاديميه محمد السادس لكره القدم من بينهم
بطبع عز الدين اوناحي نايف اجرد ويوسف
انسيري الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم فيفا
اشاد بالدور الريادي الذي لعبته
الاكاديميه في تطوير اللعبه في المغرب
[تصفيق]
تابعا لاكاديميه محمد السادس لكره القدم
وحلولها اجتياز اختبار وطني ينتقي امهر
اللاعبين
تلك مرحله
100 لاعبي
يخدعون حاليا لتكوين رياضي علمي داخل
الاكاديميه
ديالهم 15 سنه ولكن في البطوله الوطنيه
للمنتخب الوطني
في كاس افريقيا اقل من 17 سنه
تاسست الاكاديميه عام 2009 على مساحه 18
هكتارا في ظرف قياسي باتت واحده من اهم
مدارس اكتشاف المواهب الكرويه قريا
في هذا العمل الجبار لكاس العالم هو ذهني
ما هو نفسي
وقيم النقيه
والشهاده
في اللاعبين اللي تخرجوا منها
القميص الوطني
بكل شراسه
من مدينه المحمديه المجاوره قديمه ابو
ايمن ليشجع ابنه الذي يحلم بان يكون ضمن
نجوم الكره مستقبلا
خلونه
عده شعبيه كبيره في عالميه
بالموازاكي مع التكوين الرياضي يتابع
هؤلاء اللاعبون مصارهم الدراسي داخل
الاكاديميه وفقا مقرراتي وزاره التعليم
صور خريجي الاكاديميه السابقين تروي
حكايات نجوم مروا من هنا اربعه منهم كانوا
ضمن المنتخب المغربي الذي شارك في مونديال
قطر يوسف
والحارس البديل رضا التكناوتي هؤلاء رفقه
بقيه الاسود صنعوا انجازا غير مسبوق للكره
المغربيه
بالاضافه الى المنتخب المغربي بفئته
المختلفه والفرق المحليه باتت فرق اوروبيه
تتحين تخريج الاكاديميه دفعات جديده
لاستقطاب افضل اللاعبين الى صفوفها
المختار العبلاوي الجزيره الرباط